[Musique]
compte tenu des préconisations annoncé
par le gouvernement dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la propagation du
coronavirus le président du département
a annoncé la fermeture des services
départementaux ce 17 mars à partir de 12
heures pour une durée de 15 jours
travailler à l'adaptation du
fonctionnement de nos services dans
l'intérêt de l'ensemble de la population
il est essentiel je dis bien il est
essentiel de tout faire pour endiguer la
propagation de l'épidémie en faisant
preuve de la plus grande solidarité
collective possible
mon devoir est d'assurer aux
réunionnaises et aux réunionnais qui
bénéficient des services du département
que notre collectivité reste et restera
toujours présente à leurs côtés des
mesures sont donc prises afin de
protéger les agents tout en garantissant
la continuité des services
une organisation spécifique permet
d'assurer les missions essentielles
envers les publics
prise en charge par la collectivité il a
fallu associer à ses missions
essentielles
les agents qui sont identifiés qui sont
compétents et qu'ils vont devoir rester
mobilisée dans le cadre d'autorisations
spéciales de présence pour mener à bien
ses missions essentielles et ce plan a
été déclenché pour les services sociaux
et médico-sociaux cinq permanences
téléphoniques sont maintenues au niveau
des territoires d'action sociale sur
l'ensemble de l'île pour joindre le
territoire d'action social est à saint
benoît faites-le 02 62 50 20 00 pour le
territoire d'action sociale ouest à
saint paul le 02 62 55 47 56 pour le
territoire d'action sociale nord à saint
denis le 02 62 20 25 25 pour le
territoire d'action sociale sud-est au
tampon le 02 62 57 60 35 et pour le
territoire d'action sociale sud ouest à
saint pierre le 02 62 96 90 00 les
services de protection maternelle et
infantile seront également joignez
grâce à des accueils téléphoniques et
des consultations à la demande pourront
être organisés les missions d'urgence et
de sécurité seront maintenus par les
équipes d'astreinte du service de
gestion des routes départementales le
traitement financier des bourses des
prestataires et des aides agricoles et
rurales est également maintenue il est
possible de joindre le numéro vert
services agricoles au 0 800 004 190 la
mise en place de ce plan de continuité
de l'activité départementale permettra
de répondre à tous les besoins
essentiels et urgents des réunionnais
[Musique]